[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et moi mon objectif ce soir c'est de
vous convaincre qu'il ya pas que les
gens qui sont gentils mais aussi les
agriculteurs tous les agriculteurs du
monde
en fait depuis dix mille ans des
agriculteurs du monde enough
il développe de nouveaux systèmes la
prairie que vous voyez là à côté de la
ferme est les pâtures et depuis milan et
donc générations entre générations les
agriculteurs perfectionnent leur système
en un siècle
en moyenne il augmente de 10 % la
production de nourriture et ça s'est
très bien passé
et puis au 20e siècle est une révolution
une révolution qui a commencé il ya
exactement cent ans ce qu'il ya cent ans
on a développé le premier maïs hybride
une plante capable d'assimiler beaucoup
d'azoté synthétique d'azov chimiques
mais pour laquelle il faut utiliser des
pesticides et insecticides faux
mécanisée et grâce à ces nouvelles
plantes
on a réussi en 40 ans à tripler la
production mondiale de céréales triplé
et donc en fait cette production
mondiale de céréales
c'était une très bonne nouvelle on s'est
retrouvé dans une situation où en fait
on pouvait d'une part assurer le
bien-être des agriculteurs d'autre part
assurer aux consommateurs une nourriture
abondante et bon marché et finalement
donner à manger aux 4 milliard de
personnes qui ont rejoint notre planète
durant le xxème siècle donc les
nouvelles étaient extraordinaires
tellement extraordinaire qu'aujourd'hui
un agriculteur canadien peut à lui seul
nourrir 5000 personnes aujourd'hui dans
une ferme du texas où il ya sept mille
vaches ont produit 150 mille litres de
lait ça aussi ça vous dit peut-être pas
grand-chose cent cinquante mille litres
de lait en fait c'est ce que vous allez
consommer dans cette salle pendant les
quatre prochaines années au texas ont
produit sain en un jour donc c'est un
modèle extraordinaire
c'est une révolution on l'a appelée
cette révolution la révolution verte est
ce que cette révolution a concerné tous
les agriculteurs du monde
mais non elle a concerné surtout les
agriculteurs du nord
et les agriculteurs d'asie aujourd'hui
80 % des agriculteurs dans le monde sont
des agriculteurs qui travaillent sur des
petites surfaces moins de deux hectares
qui travaille à la main avec une ou
comme vous voyez ici
ces agriculteurs peu ne peuvent pas
nourrir des milliers de personnes ils
nourrissent une dizaine de personnes on
se retrouve donc dans une situation où
au nord nous produisons en moyenne par
personne
mille fois plus que ce que ce que
produit un agriculteur du sud
vous imaginez l'inégalité qui s'est
installé entre le nord et le sud
en plus le miracle technologique du 20e
siècle est devenu un désastre écologique
aujourd'hui les agriculteurs complicité
pour leur productivité
à la fin du xxème siècle on les accuse
de tous les maux il des règles le crime
1 ils détruisent notre santé il abîme
notre eau ils font disparaître la
biodiversité la trajectoire prise au
xxème siècle n'avait pas pris en compte
les impacts environnementaux et
aujourd'hui il ya une chose sur lequel
tout le monde est d'accord c'est que
cette trajectoire n'est pas la bonne
pour l'agriculture il faut qu'on trouve
un autre chemin parce que ce chemin il
n'est pas tenable au 21ème siècle
vu les les problèmes climatiques vu la
limitation des ressources
ok donc qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va
chercher un autre modèle et heureusement
on a trouvé un autre modèle cet autre
modèle
il vient en fait du sud et paysans du
sud et porte un très beau nom il
s'appelle l'agroécologie l'agroécologie
ça veut bien dire ce que dit le nom ça
veut dire faire de l'agriculture et en
même temps de l'écologie ça veut dire
contrairement au modèle du xxème siècle
non plus maîtriser la nature mais être
l'alliée de la nature travailler
ensemble imiter les systèmes naturels
comme ici dans le cas de
l'agroforesterie essayer de profiter au
maximum des services que peuvent nous
fournir la nature et c'est un modèle qui
fonctionne c'est un modèle qui a été
définie au tout début il ya une
trentaine d'années en californie qui est
arrivée en europe il ya 10
avec d'autres chercheurs nous avons été
fasciné par ce modèle sont venus
s'ajouter des ong la société civile
aujourd'hui chaque année 1000 personnes
sont réunies sous la bannière d'un
projet qui s'appelle agroécologie
inaction c'est un modèle qui a même
convaincu des ministres il faut le faire
notamment le ministre français de
l'agriculture stéphane le foll qui en a
fait un projet pour la france donc c'est
vraiment une trajectoire prometteuse
pour l'agriculture et pourtant je vais
pas vous parler de ce modèle suis pas
vous parler de ce modèle parce que dix
ans après en fait la consommation de
pesticides en france a augmenté de 13%
dix ans après très peu d'agriculteurs ou
adopter le modèle de l'agroécologie
alors comment c'est possible qu'on a un
modèle qui fonctionne et que personne ne
l'adoptent
en fait c'est parce que les agriculteurs
aujourd'hui ne sont plus en capacité de
faire fonctionner leurs systèmes
ils n'ont plus de pouvoir de décision ce
n'est pas eux qui décident des prix ce
n'est pas eux qui décident de ce qu'ils
produisent et donc ils sont complètement
dépendants d'un système qui est dominé
d'une part par les films de l'agrochimie
et d'autre part par les firmes de
l'agroalimentaire et pour mieux vous
faire comprendre ça je vais prendre deux
exemples ce sera peut-être plus rapide
et plus sympa pour vous le premier
exemple qui concerne le blé tout le
monde connaît le blé et quand vous
pensez aux blés automatiquement vous
pensez aux pins blé-farine-pain sin
trilogie qui remonte à l'enfance a fait
partie de notre culture et de nos
connaissances aujourd'hui en wallonie au
produit un million sept cent mille
tonnes de blé 1 million 700 mille tonnes
de blé qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ce blé
ont fait du pain et bien non en fait
aujourd'hui en wallonie on fait du pain
seulement avec 9% du blé avec 9 % de nos
céréales fait du pain 9% alors que si
l'on voulait être autosuffisants il
faudrait utiliser 28 % de nos céréales
pour faire du pain alors que fait-on
avec les autres 91 1% avec les autres 91
1% ont fait en fait des aliments pour
animaux en majorité des biocarburants
notamment ici tout près à biot ans et ce
qui reste des 13% restants
ex porte donc le choix que le système a
fait par rapport aux céréales ce n'est
pas de les consacrer à la fabrication
d'un aliment mais c'est le dispatcher
entre ses différents usages
avec comme conséquence qu'aujourd'hui un
agriculteur wallon pourrait nourrir
mille personnes mais en réalité il n'en
nourrit que 200 ce n'est pas sa volonté
c'est la volonté du système parce qu'en
plus de ce côté un petit peu aberrant de
l'utilisation des céréales
l'agriculteur lui même quand il amène sa
benne de billets il est incapable de
savoir où elle va terminer s'il va
terminer dans un pain ou dans un bio
carburant
je vous ai promis deux exemples le
deuxième exemple que je vais prendre
c'est la question du lait en fait le
lait être éleveur et producteur laitier
c'est vraiment un boulot très dur être
éleveur et producteur laitier
c'est vraiment un boulot très dur chaque
jour de l'année vous devez trêve aux
vaches matin soir chaque jour même la
noël mais le 11 novembre
vous devez très à les vaches et quand la
fin l'année des agriculteurs laitiers
font leurs comptes
en moyenne ils n'ont rien gagné rien du
tout et les années où les prix sont
mauvais sur le marché mondial parce que
c'est le marché mondial qui détermine
les prix ils peuvent même avoir perdu de
l'argent et donc ils ont travaillé toute
une année tous les jours de l'année et
ils n'ont rien gagné à la fin de cette
année alors comment c'est possible qu'il
continue mais en fait ils continuent
grâce à vous grâce à vous parce que vous
êtes les magiciens qui leur permette de
continuer à faire du lait vous êtes des
magiciens parce que vous donnez chacun
d'entre vous chaque européen donne 100
euros par an pour la politique agricole
commune et ses 100 euros par an ils sont
là pour susciter l'agriculture et donc
en fait les agriculteurs laitiers ils
gagnent leur vie uniquement en wallonie
sur base et subsides 100 % de leurs
revenus ce sont des subsides
si on extrapole à l'échelle européenne
41 % du revenu de l'ensemble des
agriculteurs en europe c'est du subside
l'on voit le système dans lequel on est
alors bien ça s'est su zhi grâce à cette
politique agricole aux produits de plus
en plus de lait c'est génial on en
produit même tellement
quand tu sais plus quoi en faire et donc
on doit l'exporter on exporte vers
l'afrique et maintenant on commence à
l'exporter vers la chine alors seul et
je les retrouvais celle européen qu'on
exporte je les retrouvais à callas au
burkina faso où j'étais cette semaine et
accueillant le lait européens arrivent
bon il a fait pas mal de chemin d'abord
on a d'une sécheuse pour le transformer
en poutre puis il a fait 5000 km en
bateau pour arriver à dakar puis de
dakar 2300 kilomètres pour arriver à
kaya par le camion et quand il arrive à
créer un seul est il utile et vendu 45
cents du litre 45 cents du litre
c'est le prix auquel que samba diop que
vous voyez ici on va mettre la photo que
ça il est souriant mais il un peu les
boules parce que lui 45 sainte du litre
c'est le prix auquel lui achète le lait
aux producteurs locaux
il doit encore le transformer le
distribuer les distribuer dans une
petite poche plastique comme ça et
donner encore un petit peu d'argent aux
marchands en gros son lait il le vend
70% sur le marché à 75 sur le marché
vous imaginez qu'aujourd'hui parce qu'on
sur produit du lait en europe on
appauvrit et on empêche le développement
des filières du laitière dans le sud
on est dans une situation paradoxale où
contrairement à ce qu'on vous fait
parfois croire produire plus ne permet
pas de nourrir la planète
aujourd'hui a largement de quoi nourrir
l'ensemble des des personnes qui vivent
sur terre
mais le gros problème c'est qu'une
partie des paysans la planète sont parmi
les plus pauvres et souffrent de la faim
et ses paysans ils sont tués par un
système qui en fait exportent leurs
surplus vers leur pays et empêche le
développement de leur filière donc si
vous voulez retenir une chose c'est plus
on produit au nord plus on appauvrit le
sud
c'est ça la vraie équation est donc et
ça c'est pas la volonté des agriculteurs
du nord qui sont dépendants des subsides
c'est sûrement pas la volonté
agriculteurs du sud en fête
des agriculteurs du nord et du sud ils
sont en compétition
on les oppose les uns aux autres sans
qu'il ne l'ait jamais voulu
ils sont un peu comme des joueurs de
clickair vous dites à liège je crois des
joueurs d'eqii caire qui sont en train
d'être fixés sur des barres etc ont fait
jouer l'un contre l'autre en laissant
tomber toute solidarité entre
agriculture ils sont mises en
compétition et donc on est dans une
situation assez désespérante
on m'avait dit avant de venir tu vas
faire un tennis intelligent
saleh dans maman inspirant je suis pas
sûr que je vous ai inspiré jusqu'ici
j'ai plutôt l'impression que vous est
désespérée et donc il va me rester cinq
minutes dissimule en fait pour essayer
de vous convaincre qu'on a un rôle à
jouer par rapport à ça et qu'on peut
arriver à développer une autre vision de
l'agriculteur la une de notre vision de
l'agriculture
un autre modèle je vais pas beaucoup
vous parlez des solutions parce qu'on
les solutions techniques elles existent
les trajectoires
l'agroforesterie j'en ai déjà parlé
d'autres les circuits courts
l'agriculture biologique sont vraiment
des trajectoires prometteuse mais vous
l'avez compris le problème c'est pas
tellement d'avoir des solutions
le problème c'est que ces solutions se
mettre en place dans la société
alors la première chose à dire c'est que
l'agriculture basée sur le pétrole
on a une bonne nouvelle l'agriculture
dont je vous ai parlé au début
basée sur le pétrole et p6
d'insecticides elle en a pris pour 50
ans toute façon elle va disparaître
parce qu'on n'a pas les ressources pour
maintenir ce type d'agriculture
toute la question aujourd'hui c'est de
savoir comment on va faire la transition
entre ce modèle qui n'a aucune aucun
futur et un nouveau modèle c'est ça la
question aujourd'hui
alors en fait on est un peu perdu sait
pas comment faire quand vous êtes perdu
il ya deux stratégies possibles
la première c'est de commencer à marcher
êtes vous dire je vais retrouver mon
chemin un moment ou un autre c'est un
peu la stratégie qu'a d'observer un qui
développe aujourd'hui de nouveaux
modèles sans savoir vraiment vers que
l'horizon il se dirige
de mon côté j'ai choisi de me
spécialiser dans la discussion de cet
horizon dans des scénarios pour le futur
avec mon équipe on a notamment établi
des scénarios qui montre qu'en wallonie
on pourrait en 2050 se nourrir sur base
d'un modèle où il ya 40% l'agriculture
biologique et le reste est en
agriculture respectueuse de
l'environnement
ce qu'on fait en fait c'est qu'on
établit des espèces de cartes
qui permet de voir où on doit aller il
ya une carte dont on disposait c'était
celle de la révolution verte
mais cette carte elle est maintenant
dépassée elle nous en monde nous a amené
tout en haut des montagnes
mais aujourd'hui on sait qu elle nous
conduit vers un précipice donc il faut
ouvrir de nouvelles trajectoires et ses
nouvelles trajectoires
on peut les construire autour de trois
grands principes et pour chacun de ces
principes
vous avez un rôle à jouer le premier
principe c'est changer d objectif
produire toujours plus avoir une
nourriture toujours moins cher c'est
impossible c'est c'est un chemin qui
mène nulle part
ce qu'il faut faire c'est produire mieux
et payer le juste prix
on le sait alors certains modèles se
développe
j'ai parlé des circuits courts
l'agriculture biologique locale
donc on a des modèles qui fonctionnent
mais il reste à toute petite échelle et
souvent ils sont perçus comme des
modèles pour privilégier et c'est
peut-être un peu vrai alors l'autre
solution c'est de se mettre au défi de
changer des objectifs non pas un titre
individuel mais comme une société
en fait nous sommes dans une société où
nous sommes abreuvés de publicité ou nos
choix de consommation notamment
alimentaires sont totalement conditionné
je vous disais tout à l'heure que les
agriculteurs ne savait pas ce qu'on
faisait de leur blé mais vous savez vous
d'où vient à le blé qui était dans votre
pain ce matin savez vous comment il est
possible que l'on vous offrent à vous
des pizzas à 3 euros
ça vous paraît logique qu'on puisse
faire une pizza pour 3 euros
on ne sait pas et donc la première étape
si on veut changer les objectifs c'est
de demander aux systèmes plus de
transparence de s'interroger
individuellement collectivement sur la
façon dont le système fonctionne
aujourd'hui et au départ de saint de
fixer de nouveaux objectifs au système
c'est la première étape
le second principe que je vous propose
c'est de changer de cible
aujourd'hui les âges vont employer un
mot plutôt bruxellois les agriculteurs
ils sont un peu comme un veau gaulle pic
ils sont la cible
toutes les attaques les agriculteurs on
les accuse de nous empoisonner d'être de
ne pas respecter de bien-être animal
on leur demande d'arrêter d'utiliser des
pesticides comme si les agriculteurs
étaient autonomes
en fait si aujourd'hui on utilise des
pesticides notamment pomme de terre
c'est parce qu'on a décidé d'exporter 85
% les pommes de terre belge c'est pas un
choix d'agriculteurs ça c'est un choix
d'une société et donc la deuxième chose
à faire c'est changer de cible
je pense qu'il n'y a aucun espoir si la
société d'agriculture s'opposent alors
il ya des agriculteurs qui vraiment sont
des pionniers qui ont développé des
nouveaux systèmes
avec cela on a plaisir à parler mais les
autres souvent les méprise souvent on
les caricatures je pense que la deuxième
étape c'est de réconcilier la majorité
des agriculteurs avec la société
pourquoi la majorité agriculteurs parce
que la majorité des agriculteurs au
quotidien il travaille avec la nature et
donc ils ont envie eux aussi d'avoir des
systèmes plus agro écologiques et s'ils
ne le font pas ce n'est pas par mauvaise
volonté ou par incompétence mais c'est
parce qu'ils sont dans un système points
séparent le surendettement coincés par
les modèles qu'on leur impose et donc si
nous membres de la société civile nous
nous réconcilions pas avec les
agriculteurs
jamais nous ne pourrons sortir de
l'impasse dans lequel nous a mis la
révolution verte
le troisième et dernier principe c'est
un principe c'est un principe qui
mettait ça va vous étonner
j'ai vu il ya trois ans un film ce film
vous l'avez peut-être vu également
il s'appelle demain lorsque sortie du
film j'étais en colère j'étais en colère
parce que dans ce film on nous a parlé
pendant 20 minutes d'agriculture pendant
20 minutes on a vu des initiatives des
petites initiatives locales et on n'a vu
aucun agriculteur ni agricultrice aucun
agriculteur ni du nord ni du sud
comment peut-on parler d'agriculture si
on ne parle pas d'agriculteurs donc moi
je n'ai rien contre les petites
solutions
les petites initiatives elles sont très
sympathiques elle explore des
trajectoires nouvelle
mais faire croire que des vedettes de
cinéma reconverti vous nous nourrir
c'est un peu naïf ce qui nous
nourrissent et qui nourriront demain ces
agriculteurs d'aujourd'hui et de demain
et donc moi je vous propose c'est
peut-être de participer à des petits pas
c'est sympa mais en même temps d'essayer
de voir large de voir grand d'essayer
ensemble de changer de système dans
lequel nous et les agriculteurs nous
sommes coincés
ça va vous paraître impossible vous
allez dire mais nos mots n'arrivent déjà
pas à petite échelle
comment est ce que vous voulez qu'on y
arrive à grand échelle bien je vous
donne un exemple qui m'a vraiment donné
d'espoir au début de cette année au
maroc les citoyens et on ne connaît pas
l'origine du mouvement et situant décidé
de boycotter le plus grand groupe
laitier mondial et deux semaines après
quelques semaines après qu'ils aient
commencé ce boycott
le patron de ce grand groupe qui gagne
plusieurs millions d'euros par an par
ailleurs est venu au maroc et à négocier
avec les marocains en leur promettant
une agriculture plus locale et une
agriculture plus respectueuse des prix
donner aux producteurs
donc je pense que c'est possible je
pense qu'il ya moyen de voir l'arche et
donc si on a une agriculture plus
transparent des systèmes plus
transparent une réconciliation une
nouvelle annonce les agriculteurs et
qu'on se prend le problème à grande
échelle
je pense qu'il ya un avenir pour
l'agriculture toute façon c'est une
nécessité
un milliard de personnes aujourd'hui sur
la planète vivent de l'agriculture
et c'est avec eux et non contre eux que
nous devons construire ensemble une
nouvelle agriculture une agriculture qui
est plus juste une agriculture qui est
plus durable une agriculture qui est
plus belle merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]